[Musica]
[Applauso]
la prima volta che ho ascoltato questa
canzone
avevo 13 anni e mi sono venuti i brividi
nella schiena
ogni volta che ascoltavo time a dow
questo taglio ma da dan mi venivano i
brividi nella schiena dopo 40 anni
l'ascolto e mi vengono i brividi nella
schiena
allora io mi occupo di musica e di
emozioni cioè le emozioni sono una cosa
talmente forte che rimane dentro la
nostra memoria per tutta la vita e
possiamo utilizzarlo come linguaggio
comunicativo un messaggio che è talmente
forte che tante volte non riusciamo
neanche a scrivere cosa proviamo in
termini di emozioni perché è troppo
forte
l'uomo è un essere emozionale
questo lo sappiamo tutti ma io mi occupo
di musica e penso quando si ascolta un
brano questo questo brano provoca in noi
un'emozione più o meno forte più o meno
intensa anche bella anche brutta non
importa e quindi io ascolto e provo
un'emozione
la cosa bella è nello stesso momento la
persona che sta suonando quel brano a
un'emozione che è diversa senz'altro la
la mia ma è lo stesso pezzo nello stesso
momento si vivono emozioni differenti
bella cosa ancora più bella immaginare
che quella canzone o per brano sia il
risultato di una emozione
che ha avuto l'autore al compositore il
cantante quindi la musica diventa
emozione quando è nata grazie a un
emozione è emozione perché viene suonata
ed è emozione quando l'ascolto quindi la
nascita la produzione e la ricezione
sono tutte significanti in una parola
generica emozione allora possiamo
tranquillamente affermare che la musica
sia emozione nella più vasta della sua
espressione allora torna indietro e dico
l'uomo è un essere emozionale se la
musica è emozione
allora possiamo tranquillamente
affermare che l'uomo sia un essere
musicale musicale come potenzialità come
capacità non come mestiere non musicista
musicale una cosa che ognuno di noi ha
dentro e che potrebbe tranquillamente
essere utilizzata come linguaggio
comunicativo
sono più di vent'anni che mi occupo di
un progetto legato alle parole
emozionali è quando una parola non ha
nessun significato semantico ma
emozionalmente parlando trasmette tanti
messaggi
facciamo un esempio su tutti una mamma
che guarda al suo bambino piccolino di
qualche mese gli si avvicina e gli dice
fece peggio invece piace se io prendessi
un foglio e scrivessi pc pcp cpc pc
non avrebbe nessun significato 0 invece
quella mamma con quel bambino con quegli
occhi con quel sorriso con quello
sguardo con quella voce con
quell'intenzione fece pc e pc e pc
vuol dire tantissimo tantissimo quasi 17
anni fa divento papà per la prima volta
non l'ho fatto tante volte un paio la
prima volta mia figlia
2 chili e tre mesi uno scricciolo duomo
che piange come uno squalo
siamo a carpi in una sala di un rooming
in e lei nasce alle quattro e mezza del
pomeriggio alle dieci e mezzo di sera di
ancora che piange mia moglie di vaste va
stata dalla cosa la signora che alloggia
insieme a noi
anche allora non sapendo come fare a un
certo punto io prendo mia figlia martina
l'appoggio sul braccio e cominciò
agitarla modello sheikh ed a porto fuori
cercando di dare un attimo di sollievo a
queste due povere donne che mamma mia e
cammino nel corridoio da solo con
martina nel braccio e mentre cammino mia
figlia automaticamente smette di
piangere
e io non mi fermo più e continua a
camminare
e siccome questo è il mio mestiere
questo effettivamente è uno shake e
quindi senza accorgermi a un certo punto
comincio a fare e poi siccome c'è uno
shake anche un tamburo ci sta e di
conseguenza mi viene così e camminando
nel corridoio dico con martina bomb
martina sorride e si addormenta e io ero
davanti e che stiamo scherzando e quindi
io e la mia martina abbiamo questa
parola che non significa niente cicchi
bonn
ma c'è chi può ma è semplicemente dello
shake and bone del tamburo bon bon chic
bon bon chic baschi blu tratto tac tac
tac tic tac tic tac martina dorme
tutte le volte che dobbiamo far dormire
martina c'è chi però non gomez e
funziona funziona
martina diventa un po più grande ed è
lei che chiede papi mi cantici keepon e
per farla addormentare i vettori e canto
bambaci kibaki e martino si addormenta
passano sette anni finalmente riesco a
realizzare questo progetto legato alla
parola sonora che si chiama ct bob un
libro cd per bambini 0 3
vado a casa la prima persona che ascolta
questa realizzazione mia figlia quindi
entro in casa chiamo martina senza di
aver niente dico martina ascolta quando
il cd lo metto dentro dello stereo
accendo martina è di chi ascolta mattina
al 7 anno con la scorsa dice papi ma
sono io non addormentato di parole per
ora abbiamo davanti
facciamo un gioco pensate a una parola a
una qualsiasi parola una sola una sola
parola che può essere una parola un
verso un suono un modo di dire quello
che volete ma deve essere soltanto una
così vediamo se questa cosa funziona ci
avete davvero allora io adesso d'accordo
con lo staff di ted chiamerei sul palco
i relatori e non lo sapevano quindi ieri
dato i cortesemente se vengono sul palco
tutti i relatori poi chiamò il sindaco
perché io sindaco abbiamo ormai un
rapporto
se sì dove sono io c'è il sindaco ci
mettiamo così sì esattamente
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 e 8
benissimo allora è molto facile questo
microfono funziona no così così è
perfetto allora fatemi fa terminare
un'espressione un 123456789 piceno tu mi
fai da super solista
ok eh si si eh si si ebbe lista
l'eleganza allora dunque voi dovete
avere in mente un suono un suono nel
senso la parola che avete scelto una
sola parola
l'unica cosa che vi chiede questa la
parola che avete in mente deve essere
espressa nel modo più emozionale
possibile quindi il divieto è parlare
con voce neutra tipo se devo dire domani
non posso dire domani queste google non
prevalente deve essere una cosa
emotivamente importante
prendi il tuo che è meglio
agrate l'età e le tappe bene quindi una
sola parola allora posso spostare un
attimo super solista tipo di mettere qua
se sì allora sta attenta state attenti
siccome stiamo parlando di musica c'è un
beat voi non pensate di essere esclusi
da questo sistema non è così questo è un
bit
il gioco è molto facile io parto da lei
e faccio appoggiano microfono e loro
seguendo questo pitt
mi devono tenere il tempo e devono dirmi
questa parola nel modo più emozionale è
possibile poi poi possono scegliere
arrabbiato contento triste annoiato
spensierato quello che vuoi
la parola che vuoi però che esprima un
qualcosa di emozionale
ok adesso sono solo curioso di sentire
che parole vengono qua ecco proprio 9
nov a benedirla però ogni volta che la
ditte 2 pd e ma sempre uguale spiaggia
cuore possiamo togliere questo cielo
vita loose e libertà felicità funesta
cosiddetto così ancora foresta nera più
bello prima la livi detta meglio prima
tolgo questo dà fastidio
scusate così è più facile così bene
allora ritorno spiaggia quasi cielo vito
luce libertà felicità foresta
adesso lo faccio senza in modo tale che
non lo possano esprimersi fine un
pochettino più di voce questo è il beat
ok che cosa succede e io ho quindici
minuti fa mi mandano li lega foresta no
no no no alla foresta
se dobbiamo stato affinato la foresta
no è no allora adesso e bosco
no no no cosa vuoi allora bosco va bene
e vi preoccupate forest ma no ma andava
bene lo stesso in correità ricomincia
celo celo celo celo celo vita attenta è
attenta dai perfetto allora state
attenti per quando mi giro verso di voi
facciamo così
voi dovete fare uno starnuto fortissima
così proviamo bravi attenti e io mi giro
quando voglio quindi faccio così dai
ragazzi mi giro e faccio bravi attenti
no ma no ma aspetta faccio il jazz ci
vogliono tre te per fare questa cosa qua
te li facciamo sei pronta di vita
luce luce luce luce luce luce luce
libertà luce è recitato libertà felicità
libertà boss devo credere che toccava
the felicità grazie grazie
una sola canzone fatta di una sola
parola esprime molto più significato di
tantissime parole buttate li vediamo se
ce la facciamo stato mai stati ventilati
bravissimi belle mamma tele ma mai e
vele mamma pelle ma mai e belem amabile
mamma del e mamma mamma mamma vele mamma
bene ma mai bene mamma bene ma mai bene
ma va bene ma ma per sé ma va bene ma va
bene ma va bene ma mai
bene mamma bene ma mai bene mamma bene
mamma
ma no bene bama delle mamma e le mamma
belle ma belle ma mai belle ma belle ma
va bene ma va bene ma mai era bell'e
mamma beve mamma e papà
belle mamma pelè ma mai bene ma va bene
ma ma belem amabile ma mai bene mamma
beve ma va bene ma pan de re ma la vera
mamma bere ma mai voi bene in mano la
madre malata
berna
ma non va bene
papà
ma mai
ancora bene mamma
[Musica]
bene mamma
va bene ma va bene mamma belle ma maglie
[Musica]
[Applauso]